you do have the ability to switch to
your offhand weapon while on horseback
this one drove me crazy for a while guys
it seems like such a simple one that i
knew there had to be a way to do this in
the game maybe it even tells you in the
game and i just completely missed it by
default your right hand weapon will be
equipped when you're riding horseback
pressing l1 however doesn't use your
left hand weapon instead it uses your
right hand weapon but swings on the left
side now i'm playing as a mage right now
and i usually like running with my staff
and my left hand and my sword in my
right hand of course you can see the
problem here whenever i hop on my horse
i couldn't figure out a way to switch to
the staff in my left hand but this one's
actually super simple all you have to do
is press the button combination for two
handing your weapon while you're on
horseback so for ps4 ps5 this is going
to be triangle and r1 at the same time
again if you're on horseback rather than
two-handing your right-hand weapon it
will instead switch to your left-hand
weapon now if you're a mage like me and
running the staff in your left hand you
will have to use r1 to cast the spells
when you're on horseback